So, we are here in Dearborn, Michigan,
guys, doing street evangelism, planting
seeds, reaching out to Muslims. And
listen, there's only one thing we do
around here. AND WHAT'S THAT, Y'ALL? WE
JUST READ. WE JUST READ. WE JUST READ.
WE JUST READ. WE JUST READ. WE JUST
READ. WE JUST READ. WE JUST READ. WE
JUST READ. WE JUST READ. WE JUST READ.
WE JUST READ. WE JUST READ.
IT'S GOD. [music]
It's God. [singing]
It's God.
Oh.
>> logic.
>> Yeah. What's up, bro? [laughter] What's
up?
I seen you debate
You debate
Orthodox Muslims.
>> Orthodox Muslims, Sheikh Imam, all of
those dudes. I'm willing to have any
debate. Huh? I'm willing to have any
conversation.
>> Sure. Okay, yeah. We can talk about um
I'm willing to have any conversation.
Yeah, yeah.
>> That's dope, man. You want to try to
prove Jesus is a Muslim for $2,200?
Oh.
>> [snorts]
>> Come on, man. Hold on. I'll hold this.
Okay. Good gracious. It's a magnet.
>> camera for me.
Mhm.
Hold on.
All right. I'm willing to put up the
$100 to test what your name, buddy?
Oh, no. Mohammed. Mohammed. Nice to meet
you. Nice to meet Word, man. You got
some friends, Mohammed? You want to find
your friends Yeah. You going to call
your friends up? Tell them
[clears throat] to come on down and you
can win $2,200 right now. All my friends
are working right now. Oh, they all
working.
>> Yeah.
All right. We all set. All right. Also.
All right, guys. So, we got our friend
uh Mohammed who pulled up, man. Said
he's uh willing to have a discussion. I
think that a easy one is uh Jesus being
a Muslim. That's a common one that we
usually see.
>> Yeah, how was he? He He prayed the same
way that Muslims pray. Okay. And tell me
how how that was. How do you guys pray?
Um Jesus bowed his head down to the
ground and he worshipped the one creator
and God never claimed Jesus never
claimed to be God. Okay. Okay, so he
bowed his head to the ground, never
claimed to be God and so these would
follow him
or meet the criteria of being a Muslim
you would say. Yeah. All right, so let's
say I bow my head to the ground. I don't
claim to be God
but I believe in one God, one creator.
Yeah. But the God that I'm speaking
about that I bow down to is a tree in my
backyard. Okay, would you say that I'm a
that I pray like a Muslim?
No, because a Muslim means to submit to
the one true God. A tree is tree is an
object. It's not a God. It's not a
creator. Good. So you're saying that you
have to have the true concept of God
that you submit to in order to be a
Muslim, right? Yeah. Okay, good. And so
In Islam it says you can't worship
idols. So a tree would be an an an idol,
an object. It wouldn't be a
>> If you worship anything that's not God,
wouldn't that be an idol? Like if I if I
said that my mom is God, she's she
become my idol. Would you would you
agree with that? Yeah, that doesn't
align with Islam. I agree with you.
Okay, so so you have to have the true
concept of God that matches God in
Islam, right? Yeah. Okay. So when Jesus
prayed and he prostrated cuz you're
right, he did prostrate when he prayed a
few times.
Um
there's a verse because there's a
there's a an instance where we see it
and he prostrates he says, "My father,
if it be possible, let this cup pass
from me but not my will, let your will
be done." Right?
>> Okay. So he's saying that God is his
father when he prostrates and prays. Is
that how Muslims pray that you guys
prostrate and you refer to God as your
father?
We don't refer to God as our father, no.
Then you don't pray like Jesus.
Jesus said that oh I'm praying to my
father. Right, and do Muslims pray to
their father in heaven?
We pray to one true God. We don't refer
to him as a father. So you don't pray
like Jesus.
Well, we don't we don't believe
everything in the Bible is correct. We
believe it was corrupted. Okay. We
believe some aspects of it, but we don't
believe the entire story.
>> I'm not going to lie to you, Mohammed. I
expected you to say that. So, in
expecting you to say that, I have a
question, okay? Okay.
>> [laughter]
>> So, what that question then is, since
the Bible's corrupted,
then how do you know that Jesus
prostrated when he prayed? How do you
know?
Where do you get that from? I got it
from your own book, the Bible.
But, it's corrupted. Well, yeah. The
point of meaning of corruption means
that we believe something to be true. We
don't believe everything in the Bible is
correct.
>> how do you know that it's true when it
says Jesus prostrated?
Because that's We just know it's true.
Like, it's something because it says in
your own Bible. So, we don't believe
everything, but it says it there itself.
I got you. So, this what I'm saying.
It's It's It's inconsistent reasoning to
say that
part of this scripture is true, and then
as in another part of that same verse is
not true. It's not consistent because
that's what it's called confirmation
bias. You're only
leaning on what you like, and what you
agree with, and you're disregarding what
you don't like, right? So, in the same
verse that says Jesus prostrated, it
says that he called God his father, you
know what I'm saying? So, you can't take
one part of the verse and and reject the
other part. That'll be inconsistent.
Okay, but I mean, Christians do that
same logic. You get In the In your own
Bible, it says you can't eat pork, but
Christians eat pork all the time.
>> Well, that's that's that's the old law
versus the new law. Like, even in the
So, but do you believe in the Old
Testament?
>> Yeah, of course, but So, why do you one,
but not the other? No, it's not that we
don't take one. It's just that one is
lawful and one isn't in a certain time.
Even you would like you would agree that
like remember alcohol in Islam used to
be lawful, but then now then Allah
forbade it, right? Yeah. So, there was a
So, in there's one part of the Quran
where it's okay to drink alcohol. You
get it later in the Quran, he out he out
outlaws it completely. It doesn't mean
that that
>> Not in one verse. It says that in
another says that. We just believe at a
certain time, yeah. Exactly. That's what
I'm saying. So, at one point, there was
a law of Moses where pork is not
allowed, all these other foods is not
allowed. Under the new law of the of of
the Messiah, more food is allowed.
>> it say in the new law? Well, well,
that's that's another subject. But,
specifically on this subject we're
talking about not picking and choosing
simply what we agree with and then not
going with what disagrees with us, you
know? We got to be consistent. If we're
going to go to the verse where Jesus
prostrated, then we have to take that he
prostrated according to the word to his
father, you know? Okay, sure. You could
Sure, you can make the argument based
off the Bible and what it says. But, how
do you believe that Jesus is praying to
the same God that you pray to, the Holy
Spirit, Father,
and him being the son? How would he pray
to himself?
>> We we we can get to that next, I promise
you. Cuz these are these are legit
questions and I want to talk about that.
But, first I want to make sure that we
can establish that at least according to
the Bible, Jesus is not a Muslim by what
he believed. Can we agree with that?
With the entirety of the Bible and
Christianity and the authors that all
wrote it after a certain, yeah. Okay.
Doesn't represent Islam.
>> Right. So, so the Jesus in the Bible
does not represent Islam. So then, can
we then say that objectively and
historically Jesus is not a Muslim?
No, why why would you conflate the two?
We we believe that some parts of the
Bible, some aspects
show him show it showing showing him
having aspects of being a Muslim. But,
obviously the parts that like Paul and
Pe- Peter and all these unknown au-
authors wrote afterwards, it doesn't
it doesn't it show the full Islam. It
doesn't full doesn't show the full
message of Islam, which is why the Bible
we believe obviously isn't the full
correct word of God. So, so let's do
this then. Let's do this. Let's
So, the the prostration verse doesn't
work. Maybe there's another verse that
demonstrates that Jesus was a Muslim in
authentic way.
What what do you have in mind that in
the Bible shows that Jesus is a Muslim?
Um
I'm trying to think of what you said
earlier.
Well, the main thing for me I feel like
is that
the the God that you guys follow this
Trinity with three in one, how would
Jesus
we all okay we both can agree Jesus was
sent from God, right?
>> Wait, he was what?
>> Jesus was sent from God, right?
Why would Jesus be praying to himself? A
Trinity that includes himself.
How would that make sense?
Well, that cuz that's that's not the
Trinity. That's modalism. We don't
believe that Jesus is the Father. Jesus
is the Son. So, he's a distinct person.
So, they can communicate with each
other. But what would they talk about?
So, hold on. Hold on. This is my thing
though. With Jesus acknowledging and
talking and praying to the Father, that
belief in its in and of itself takes him
out of sight of the fold of Islam.
So, the very the very thing that you're
appealing to is showing that Jesus is
not a Muslim. What takes him out of the
fold of Islam? Right. By By yeah, by
claiming that God is his father. Right?
Cuz in Islam obviously Allah doesn't
begin or is he begotten. There's no
children, right? No sons, no daughters.
So, to say that he has a son, the Quran
says that's an atrocious thing to even
utter such a thing, right? It doesn't
befit him to have a son.
I mean
that I feel like we just we can go back
and forth. You can say oh well I believe
the Bible says that and I would believe
it to be true. I could say that I
believe that oh this aspect of the Bible
is true but the rest is corrupted. I
don't believe that. We can go back and
forth about that but my my overall claim
is to say that
I don't believe Jesus claimed that oh
I'm the son of the Father.
>> Right. So, where then where So, that's
what I'm saying. If you're if you're
going to show someone if you're going to
prove to them that they're a Muslim or
that Jesus was a Muslim, sorry. Yeah.
You're you keep going to the Bible
to prove it as your evidence. But when
we look at the evidence it actually
proves the opposite that he's not a
Muslim.
You know what I'm saying? I'm not I'm
not just appealing to the Bible. We can
also say that Okay. the fact that well,
why would Jesus pray to a trinity that
includes himself? Why would God Why
would God pray to God with him being
himself? You know what
>> doesn't tell me what wouldn't this show
that he's not a Muslim if he's doing
that?
Yeah. So he's not a Muslim. No, so the
Bible is corrupted and isn't correct.
>> [laughter]
>> That's what I'm saying. So if the
Bible's corrupt, put Bible throw Bible
away. Cuz Bible's corrupt, we can't rely
on the Bible to give us true information
about Jesus. So we're back at square
one. How would you prove to me with
evidence that Jesus actually was a
Muslim? That his beliefs lined up with
the beliefs of Islam.
Um
What Okay, the reason I'm saying is that
I just don't believe the trinity is true
and I don't see how Jesus praying and
prostrating aligns with that. Like for
example
>> you. So let's look all that's out. How
would you prove to me that Jesus is a
Muslim with something that is authentic
that we can actually point to that to
give us truth about Jesus.
Well, what why can't you go with that
argument? With what? With the fact that
why would Jesus be praying to a trinity
that includes himself? And how does the
trinity even make sense?
>> That's That's not telling me that if
That's not has nothing to do with Jesus
being a Muslim. Let Let's Let's Let's
Let's grant that Jesus never taught the
trinity or whatever. Let's Let's grant
this. He never taught the trinity.
How would we know what Jesus believed?
How How do we know what what he taught?
Because the things he taught align A lot
of it does align with Islam. What he
taught aligns
>> Where Where are you going to get his
teachings to see that he aligns? We
could see the Bible.
You see where we're going? You keep
doing it. So look, we I put the Bible
aside.
>> Well, what about the Quran? The Quran
does too. The Quran says what Jesus
taught.
>> The Quran is the what is in question.
The Quran is making a claim about Jesus,
right? And so I'm like, okay, I want to
investigate what the Quran is saying. In
order for me to investigate I have to go
back to what Jesus actually taught to
see if what the Quran is saying is true
about it, right? Does that make sense?
Like if I wanted like if Jesus is
saying, "Hey, you know, Moses spoke
about me right in the gospel." I'm not
going to just use the gospel to be like,
"Yeah, Moses spoke." No, I'm going to go
to the Torah to see if what Jesus is
saying about Moses is correct. So, it's
the same here. When the Quran is
speaking about Jesus, it's appealing to
a source that comes before it, right? To
help verify it, which would be the
gospel.
You know? So, you can't say the gospel's
corrupted as soon as it refutes Islam.
That's That wouldn't be fair thinking.
But do you believe the Bible is the word
of God? Yes, the Quran says that.
No, the the the modern Bible that we
have right now after all of the authors,
many unknown, that wrote it.
You believe that still it's a complete
unfailable word of God even after that?
>> Yes, I think cuz the Quran says
The Quran says the gospel that was that
the Jews and Christians have is the
truth. It's revelation from God from
Allah.
At a certain time, not the modern Bible
we have today. So, So, when do you think
it stopped being the word of God? When
did it stop?
I don't know that when before the
before the certain authors corrupted it
and started adding things that
>> When would that have been? Would that
have been like maybe before Muhammad
became a prophet? Maybe after?
Before Muhammad. Okay. So, before
Muhammad became a prophet, the
scriptures were already corrupted, which
is why he comes to clean up everything.
Is that right? Okay. So, if we're going
with this talk, all right? Okay. The
Quran says
in Muhammad's time [clears throat] to
the Jews and Christians Okay. Okay. to
believe this chapter 2 verse 41. It
says, "Believe in what we have sent down
confirming that which is already with
you."
Right? Okay. So, the Quran came
and it says that it confirms what is
already with the Jews and Christians,
the scriptures they have.
If the scriptures they have are already
corrupted, this would mean that Allah
and the Quran are confirming corrupted
books saying that corrupted books are
true. Yeah. The Quran talks
before it was corrupted though. No, it
says what's with them. Remember, it's in
Muhammad's time it says but talking to
the Jews and Christians, "Believe in
what we have sent down confirming that
which is with you, which is with you,
not from before, but what they presently
have."
You get what I'm saying?
So, they So, what they have, the Quran
has confirmed. The scriptures they have
in Muhammad's time, the Quran is saying
is true.
Were those scriptures be corrupted?
I believe it was. So, then that would
mean that Allah is confirming corrupted
books.
Can Can I pull up the verse actually? It
says that Okay, sure. Chapter two.
Okay.
On what?
I'm not live on YouTube.
Oh, live Oh, that's live? Oh.
Um
Yeah. Okay, wait. Do you know the
chapter? Okay. Chapter two, verse 41.
They're saying that the audio's kind of
cutting. How's it sound now, guys?
>> [clears throat]
>> You came out here with a short sleeve
and shorts, bro. I know you cold, man.
Ain't no way.
>> [laughter]
>> Okay.
And believe in what I have sent down
confirming that already with you.
Yep. How is that saying at the time?
It's saying what in the time of
Muhammad?
Yeah, so believe in what we have sent
down, which is the Quran. That's the
Quran that he sent down. Yeah.
Confirming that which is already with
you.
So, the Quran came down confirming the
scriptures that's already in existence.
The scriptures they have with them.
You understand what I'm saying?
Yeah.
So, the scriptures they have with them
have to be true. That's what the Quran
is saying. They're saying that it's
true, not corrupted.
Let me ask you.
Is that a chat? Uh Gemini, yeah. Okay.
>> Okay, yeah.
Yeah, I just had a question about
Photoshop.
I mean, I am interested to see what what
they will answer to that.
You know, I watch you all the time.
You're always on my Tik Tok. I thought
this today [laughter] I was watching
you.
I didn't know you were here.
>> Yeah, that's so funny.
Yeah.
That's cool. That's really cool.
I mean, yeah. It's
It's not what it's saying. It's
literally saying
it refers to the original divine message
revealed. So, they have the original
divine messages with them then, right?
Cuz it says it's with them.
See, notice if this is trying to give a
defense or trying to say that the
scriptures are corrupted, it's not going
to make any sense.
Cuz remember it it says it's confirming
what is with them, not
what they used to have. What's with them
currently.
Mhm.
Yeah, no. [clears throat] It's literally
saying my argument.
Sure. Look, when it says with them it's
it's talking It's not talking about the
full the entirety of it. It's talking
about the parts that aren't corrupted.
Where did it say that?
It said it's confirming what is with
them, not part of what is with them.
You know what I'm saying?
>> Okay, now you're just going to like the
semantics of it. Yeah, confirming. Why
would it be confirming what's with them?
Why would it even need to be confirmed
if it's It's been corrupted? That's the
whole reason.
>> Exactly. That's the point. If it's
corrupted, then the Quran shouldn't be
corrupt confirming books that are
corrupted. So, why wouldn't? That's the
whole point of the Quran to confirm to
Not to confirm corrupted books. If it's
corrupted, then it's not true. When
you're confirming something, you're
saying it's true. Do you know what
corrupted means? Corrupted means part of
it is true, not Corrupted doesn't mean
the entire thing isn't true. If if the
Quran else says, so if somebody had
mixed in some stuff from the Quran,
yeah, would it still be the word of God?
In part. So so if somebody picked up a
Quran that had a mixture of of what
let's say I don't know Uthman put in
there or something like that.
>> Okay. Would you would would it still be
considered the Quran and the word of
Allah? And what in part? No, it
wouldn't. Why wouldn't it?
>> be considered a corruption and then
they'd behead Uthman for that.
>> It's it's a corruption, but parts of it
are from God. Okay, so would you would
would you be commanded to believe in
that? Would you be would you believe in
a would you say that hey I'm confirming
this book that's mixed with truth and
falsehood? Why are you putting it like
grouping it as one? I would in part. If
let's say 10 pages are 100% the word of
God, right?
>> Yeah. Uh yeah, I would follow those 10
pages, not the parts that have been
corrupted by Uthman.
>> me this favor then. Go to go to chapter
2 verse 85. Okay. So I'm going to show
you the Quran answers all of this,
brother. This idea of believing in parts
and all that, Quran answers this. Okay.
Chapter 2 verse 85.
So you believe in part of the scripture
and disbelieve in part.
See, and it's talking about how the Jews
were picking some parts of the scripture
they believe in and rejecting other
parts [clears throat] that that that
they disagree with. So and then it says
that if you those who do so among you
will be disgraced in this life and a
severe torment will await for them here.
That's a whole different context.
>> No, it's it's the same thing. The
context of that is saying that okay,
let's say let's say in your Bible,
right? You um you worship Jesus, you
love Jesus and his father and and the
Holy Spirit, but you um you kill people,
you sin, you um
you're always You're always sinning.
>> yeah. That's what it's saying. It's
saying all you believe in the part about
Jesus, but you don't believe in about
the part that where he's saying that
this is permitted, it's not something we
should do. That's what it's referring
to. It's referring
>> So I have to believe in all of the
scripture, right? I can't believe in
part of it. I got to believe in all of
it, right?
>> Of the scripture that is
said to be 100% complete and true, yeah.
So then so then why is it if there Why
is Allah cuz you're saying that their
scripture is corrupted? So, why is Allah
telling them to believe in all of their
corrupted scripture? Telling who to
believe in all of the The Jews.
Because
If it's corrupted, you're saying you can
you can believe in part of it, not the
corrupted parts. That's what you said
earlier.
But Allah says that they have to believe
in all of their scripture. Well, that's
a whole different context though. This
is talking about at the time. It's in
Muhammad's time. This is saying This is
referring to something that was
corrupted according to Islam. Okay, so
if it's corrupted, why is Allah telling
them to believe in the entirety of a
corrupted book?
It's saying for them like Okay, let's
say for you, would you be righteous in
your religion if you followed only part
of the Bible and not the other part? I
would not.
I wouldn't be righteous. That's what I'm
saying. So so they So, Allah's telling
them to follow the entire scripture,
right? Yeah. So then that means that
Allah is telling them to follow the
entirety of a corrupted book. The good
parts and the bad parts?
Um I don't know exactly what's referred
to in this verse, but um it's referring
to the Torah.
You're saying the Torah is corrupted. Is
this what I'm saying? Was it referred to
the Torah we have now or the Torah when
we
>> In Muhammad's time. The Torah in
Muhammad's time. It says for the Jews
that they're picking and choosing the
parts that they choose to believe in and
obey. So, Allah's reprimanding them and
using Muhammad to get on them for that.
And so he says, "You are not to believe
in part of the scripture and reject
other parts. If you do that, you're
going to go to hell."
So, he lays that statement. Isn't that
referring to the corruption
like in its in its essence like how do I
explain it?
That's what it That's what it
That's probably what he means when he
says it's corrupted. Like he believes
that the Jews are following this part
and this part, but they're they're
ignoring all of this
and they're adding in this,
making it corrupted.
>> No, it's look this is you saw the verse.
Do you believe in part of the scripture
and reject other parts? So, Allah is
getting on them for believing in some
verses and not believing in other verses
in the same book.
You're telling me that this book is
corrupted. So, there's some truth in it,
other falsehood in it.
So, they should only be believing in
part of it, but Allah is saying for them
not to believe in the part, but to
believe in all of it.
So, either Allah is telling them to
believe in all of a book that's
corrupted, so they have to believe in
falsehood too, or the book is not
corrupted, which is why they have to
believe in all of it or else they'll go
to hell.
You know what I'm saying? Yeah, look
listen I I got to look specifically into
that verse and like why he's saying
that.
>> Doesn't make sense though? I I got what
you're saying, yeah, but
Look, I I know it's getting off topic,
but I want to understand
how you believe in the Trinity. Yeah, I
I know you do, but this is important,
bro. Okay, I I haven't I don't know the
exact context of that and
all about that, but But as long as you
can be honest about what the verse is
saying and I and the reasoning that I'm
getting. Like if you can you see the
reasoning in what I'm saying and make it
sense? You see it? I get your point,
yeah.
>> Okay, so with this point being made,
there's no way that the scripture I mean
well
it's it's two options. Either like I
said, the scripture is corrupted and
Allah is telling them to believe in
corrupted books
or
it's it's preserved, which is why Allah
is still telling them to believe in all
of it. You know? What do you think?
>> even make sense. Then why why would the
Quran be what it is? Why would Muhammad
even be sent from God? It doesn't even
make sense.
>> Exactly, that's the point. The point is
>> So, so he did it all for no reason?
>> My my point my point is is that this
proves that Muhammad is not really a
prophet. He's not sent from God because
of this reason. The The fact that he
said the fact that the Quran says the
scriptures are true, but then Mohammed
contradicts those scriptures shows that
Mohammed is not a true prophet. Because
if those scriptures are true, he has to
be in line with them.
But if he contradicts them, he's false.
If these scriptures are corrupted and
he's still saying that these scriptures
are true while they're corrupted, then
he's still false for saying corrupted
books are true.
That would make him a false prophet.
It'll make him a false prophet because
he's saying God is telling him this
stuff.
Let me ask you this. I don't know the
historical context.
285 is about tribes that were
basically turning on their own people.
Jews were turning on their own people
against their enemies.
And that goes against some parts of the
some parts of the Torah.
Well, yeah. It's It's saying that at the
time when they they hid things and
they're so very selective with it. It
was It's saying that you should have
followed the entirety of it.
So, but would Allah tell them to follow
the entirety of a corrupted book?
No, right? Corrupted in the way where
they they're selective with it. They
they they hid things.
>> it. So, so the scripture itself isn't
corrupted, but the people are.
Is that right? Cuz they're the ones
selectively choosing what they believe
in. They're hiding or ignoring what
verses go against them. So, it's not
that the text is corrupted, but the
people are acting corruptly with the
text. Is that Is that better to say? I
mean, that's what we believe with the
Bible as well.
>> Awesome. So, so you don't believe that
the Bible's actually corrupted. You
believe that the people the people
themselves are corrupted and they're not
following the Bible correctly. Is that
right? In part, no. For for the Bible, I
mean, we we feel that there are authors
that
we know that there are authors that
corrupted it. Authors that added things.
Authors that took out certain things.
>> Got you. So so you do believe that the
text is corrupted.
Not just the people. You believe the
actual book, the actual text is is
messed up.
Okay. So going with this, you and I I
hope you see the problem. If the text is
messed up,
Allah is telling them to believe in all
of that text that is messed up.
Why would Allah, who's supposed to be a
true God, in truth, loving, all-knowing,
why would he tell people to believe in
all of a book that is messed up?
That has falsehood in it.
Maybe it's just trying to show a point
that they're being hypocrites. Like if I
were to follow something and I follow it
to a T, why would I be taking out parts,
being selective about it? That changes
my core beliefs.
>> Nope. Because according to
I'll tell you what. The Torah is Allah's
revelation.
The Gospels Allah's revelation.
That's why he's telling them to follow
it. Because he revealed these books.
They have to follow these books cuz he
revealed them. It's his word. Right? So
it's not the same with the pagans. Like
with the pagans, they're not allowed to
follow their religion. Right? Muhammad
went and crushed their idols because
they're false gods. Right? So Allah
didn't reveal that. So that's why they
they weren't allowed to do that. But the
Jews and Christians, they had to follow
their scripture cuz it's revelation from
God. Guidance and light for the people.
Right? So with the Torah now, if if
they're picking and choosing what the
what they believe of Allah's word, they
get a punishment. They're they're being
hypocrites with Allah's word, which is
why the punishment is so hard in that
verse. He says, "For those who do this
among you, who are picking part to
believe in, rejecting other parts, those
who do that are disgraced in this life
and will go to hell in the hereafter."
That's how serious Allah takes people
who pick and choose of his scripture.
Yeah, and that's what it's saying. Okay,
so then they can't pick and choose of
the scripture because the scripture is
true.
Right?
Yeah. So which means that it's not
corrupted. It can't be corrupted if
Allah's saying to believe in all of it.
But do you get what I'm saying like my
point of
it's he's talking about if you're going
to follow something, you should not be
selective. They should not be
hypocrites. And that's what it is.
>> No, you're not You're not allowed to
follow just anything. We have to follow
his revelation. That's it. Jews that
referring to those people, not everyone
in the world. Right, so the Jews Yeah,
so the Jews are supposed to follow the
Torah. Like they have to because it's
Allah's revelation because it's true.
Right? So yeah, so they have to believe
in all of the Torah. They can't believe
in some of it. They have to believe in
all of it. Which means that all of the
Torah is true.
Allah's not going to tell them to
believe in a lie, right? Or something
that's messed up or corrupted. But
they're select but then they became
selective with it.
>> Exactly, so the it's not the book that's
messed up. It's the people. The people
are messed up and misusing the book in
that they're not following it correctly.
>> Yeah. So the text though, the text of
the Torah is still intact. It's still
good. They have to follow it all, but
some of them aren't. So the people are
That's like it's like you if you were
to, you know, you take the Quran and you
follow some parts of it and reject other
parts because you don't you don't want
to follow that part.
>> Yeah. That's But that don't mean that
the Quran is messed up. It means you're
messed up.
Right?
>> Yeah. So the same thing with the with
the Torah and the Gospel.
Yeah, what what's the issue with them?
So the the issue is is that you have to
change
The issue is is that you have to change
your mind now. Instead of saying that
the Bible has been corrupted, say that
the people
>> Bible? This is referring to the the
Torah.
>> in a Okay, I'll say Torah. So instead of
saying that the Torah is corrupted or
the Gospel's corrupted, say that the
people are corrupted, not the not the
scriptures. The scriptures are preserved
and intact and true.
It's the people that have messed up.
Um
at the time, sure you could say that.
Awesome. So now here's the part here's
here's what we can say now. So since at
the time of Muhammad, the scriptures
were preserved, they were good, they
were true in Muhammad's time. This means
that what I have is the truth. Why?
Because we have what existed hundreds of
years before Muhammad. We have what
those Jews and the Christians had of the
Torah and the Gospel. But you're not a
Jew.
I Yeah, but I still have the Torah. I'm
a Christian. Christians believe in the
Torah.
Do you believe the entirety of the
Torah?
>> In the entirety of it. Absolutely.
Wait, hold on. I I I don't know I don't
know too much about it. Is it true?
What's the difference between the Torah
and the Old Testament? The So the the
Torah is five books that are within the
Old Testament. So the Old The Old
Testament is consists of a collection of
the Torah, the Psalms or the Zabur would
be in there that's given to David,
um and other writings of other prophets.
>> Didn't you just say you're you're
selective about the Old Testament and
the New Testament? No, no. What I'm
saying No, what I what I was saying
earlier No, what I what I was saying
earlier was that there were laws for a
particular time in the Old Testament and
laws that are particular time in the New
Testament. So I'm not saying that those
that wasn't true for a time or it's not
true now. Yeah, it was true that for
example, certain foods were forbidden.
But then when a new a new law comes,
uh you know, food is accessible. You
know, so I'm not rejecting it, I'm
accepting it, but we're under a new time
now.
Okay, and that's how I see it, too.
We're under a new time now. The Jews
today that follow the Torah and what
they believe and how they perceive it
and what they've done to it, it's a
different time. So we believe that at
one time at one point in time, yeah, it
was
um sent from God and they should have
It's still sent from God. You're just
saying that you don't have to follow it
anymore.
No, we're saying that
Yeah, it was it was sent from God, but
You see how you just said that, oh at
one the Old Testament said this and it
made sense.
But now the now something's not apply
cuz time changed and certain things
happen. That's exactly what I'm saying
with um
the Torah and now.
>> Sure. At a certain time, yeah, it was
the word from God. And from then to now,
it's a whole different it's it's not the
same. And that also with the fact that
um
Yeah, they're they're misselective with
it. They hit verses. So,
yeah. No, see that's I agree with you.
That's what I'm saying the same
>> thing.
>> Okay, so so we're in agreement that the
text of the scripture is true.
The text of the scripture is true just
that at a certain point in time certain
things of the scripture of past
scriptures is not applicable anymore for
a certain time.
Is that what we agree on?
Um
Yeah, I sure I I believe the Torah at a
specific point of time was correct.
No, cuz that's not something
brother, so
for example, you believe that the part
of the Quran that says that uh that
allowed for alcohol. Yeah.
>> You will you agree that that's from God,
right? Yeah.
>> Okay. So, even and you still believe
that it's from God even though that that
is not applicable anymore because
alcohol is forbidden in the Quran later
on. Yeah. Right? So, even though that
earlier allowance is no longer
applicable, you still say it's from God,
right? It's still true.
Right?
So, same thing with the Torah
is that it's still true, but
the laws in the Torah and whatever is
not applicable for you now. What's
applicable for you now is the laws in
the Quran.
Yeah.
>> Yeah? So, it's still correct. It's just
not applicable.
Right? Okay. So, um
So, this is where we're at then. So, if
when it comes to and I can I can grant
you this. I can grant you that you have
a different Sharia than what Jesus
brought or what Moses brought. You have
a different Sharia, it's a different set
of laws. I wouldn't necessarily say
there's a problem there. What the
problem is is when the theology
uh and the history collide. So, what the
prophets taught about God and who he is,
his nature, and his character, versus
what Muhammad teaches about God and his
character, right? So, like a big thing,
obviously we was talking about earlier,
Jesus teaching that God is our heavenly
father. A belief of believers. While
Muhammad is teaching through the Quran
that
no one is God's son or daughter. That
that that's impossible. He does not
accept that type of relationship. Yeah,
right? So, that's a theological
fundamental contradiction between Jesus
and Muhammad. [clears throat]
You know what I'm saying? So, and so
this is what would make Muhammad
a false prophet is that he's not in line
with what came before, like he claims to
be.
A prophet cannot contradict
the previous prophets in regards to
theology. They have to have the same
belief.
Where are you getting that grounds from?
That he contradicts what the other
prophets taught. So, yeah, when I when I
compare the Gospel and the Torah with
the Quran, right? The Quran came from
Muhammad, right? He's the one who
recited it.
So, when I compare the Quran and the
Gospel and the Torah, I see that
there's contradictory beliefs
when it comes to both to God and his
nature.
>> yeah, they're two different religions.
And that's the point. The point is is
that in in the Quran, in chapter 29, he
says, "Your God and our God are one." He
says it's the same religion. But when we
actually look at it, we see it's
completely different religions.
You know what I'm saying? So, the the
claim these claims in the Quran that
it's it's it's a continuation of the
prophets, it's the same religion of the
prophets, that claim, if we investigate
it, we're seeing that it's not the case.
It's not true.
It's a different religion.
And if it's a different religion than
what Jesus had,
then it's a false religion.
Okay, but what are you you you're using
the Bible Yes, I'm using the Gospel.
The the same thing the Quran says.
>> You have to. You have to believe in all
of all of his books. We have to believe
in the full modern Bible today.
>> Yes, all of it. Yeah, there's one God,
brother.
>> [laughter]
>> Even after all of the authors wrote and
all the churches later after Jesus died.
>> so let's let's do this for example cuz
there's a lot of assumptions here.
You're saying that there's a lot of
authors who wrote the Gospel. Yeah.
>> Right? Okay, let me ask you this cuz you
the Injil you believe in the Injil the
Gospel, right?
You believe it was written down at some
point, right? The Injil?
Yeah.
>> Okay, who would you say wrote it?
The Injil, I don't know. So anonymous.
Okay, so you believe in the Injil that
has anonymous authors.
So then why are you going against the
the Gospel if it has anonymous authors?
You believe the same thing about the
Injil.
We believe that I don't look honestly I
don't know exactly who brought forth
certain parts of the Bible. I know
Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John brought
the Gospel.
Are all of them reliable? Yeah, the
Quran says it.
The Quran says that Matthew, Luke, John,
all these people are reliable authors.
>> It says that the Injil is reliable. It
says the Injil is true, which is what
Matthew, Mark, and Okay, that's what I'm
saying. Everything after that,
everything that isn't the Injil. So so
I'll say
>> you trust that? Be because it's a it's
in line with what Jesus and the apostles
and the prophets taught.
>> If I was to say something in line with
what he taught
then does that mean I'm I'm from the
word of God?
>> No, so like what I mean is like so for
example you have Jesus who's teaching
the Gospel and his and his apostles
write it down, right? Jesus in the
Gospel taught that he's going to send
prophets and scribes. He says this in
Matthew chapter uh 23. He says, "I'm
going to send you prophets and scribes
to Israel, right?" So more messengers
are going to come from Jesus that he's
going going and scribes that he's going
to send. And then we see it happened. We
see in the book of Acts, the history of
the church, the explosion of the
believers of Jesus and how they found
the church and explode. We see it being
established exactly what Jesus said.
Everything that's happening is in line
with what Jesus said is going to happen
and what he's going to do.
>> Every single thing that's said is not
true.
How do you How do you know that? How do
you know that? I'm looking at the
connection in the history. I'm looking
at what Jesus taught and then I'm
looking at the history of the church,
the history of the apostles and I'm
seeing that it lines up with what Jesus
said in the gospel.
Okay, what's some
So you tell me you can't think of
anything that was said in the Injil
that um
isn't fully in line with um
with the apostles
Yeah, there's there's nothing that is in
the Injil that the apostles taught that
was out of line. Everything is in
>> So Jesus said he was God. Yes. Where did
he say that? Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. I'll
show I'll show you that. Okay, show me.
So you agree that
there's only certain names that that God
has, right?
Yeah. Like like certain names and
attributes that belong to him alone,
right?
>> Yeah. Okay. God has names. Right? He has
names. Who would you say is the one who
gives eternal life?
The one that gives the eternal life?
Yeah.
What do What do you mean by that? Who
gives eternal life?
What do you mean by eternal life? Like
life that never ends, paradise. Oh, God
God Allah. Absolutely. I agree with you.
Only God gives eternal life.
So watch what Jesus says here.
We go to John
chapter 10
verse 28. Wait, who is John? Was he He
was just a witness, right? He wasn't
>> He's He's an apostle. Okay. A companion.
All right.
All right. So we go to John chapter 10
verse 28. Red letters is what Jesus
said. Can you see it? Yeah. All right.
So this is Jesus speaking. It says my
sheep hear my voice and I know them and
they follow me
and I give them eternal life.
And they will never perish ever. And no
one will snatch them out of my hand.
So Jesus says
I'm the one who gives eternal life.
Obviously claiming to be God, right?
All right, you know, not a good prophet
would never say that they're the one who
gives eternal life. That would be
blasphemy.
So it's in many ways like that that
Jesus claimed to be God. You know
>> But that's from John. I I asked for
something before the apostles
>> in the gospel the gospel. This is the
gospel.
John is just writing the the gospel.
Yeah, I don't believe John to be
uh incredible source. Why not?
Why would I? He Why wouldn't you? This
is the gospel. Why would I? Tell me a
reason why I would believe Jesus
>> to tell me why you doubt. Look look
You're the one who believes it. Tell me
why you believe it.
>> example, so John is a direct disciple of
Jesus. Yeah.
You know how you have the Sahaba of
Muhammad and then the Tabi'in, right?
The companions and then those who
learned under the companions and then
generation generation. We have some of
something similar that's called
apostolic succession. People who came
after the apostles. So the students So
you have the apostles who directly
learned under Jesus. Then you have the
students of the apostles and then their
students and then their students and so
on and so on, okay? Yeah. Apostolic
succession. The people who succeeded the
apostles.
So we have that. Within the apostolic
succession, within our generation, we
have a chain of authorship. You guys
have chain of narration in Hadith. We
have a chain of authorship, meaning the
church fathers the early Christians were
unanimous on who wrote the gospel.
And they always say Matthew wrote
Matthew. Matthew the disciple, the tax
collector, wrote Matthew. Luke the
physician wrote the gospel. Um
Mark wrote the gospel at the dictation
of Peter.
And John wrote his gospel after them
because people asked him to do it. All
of them unanimously say the same thing.
There's never any disagreement within
early church. Okay, but you you don't
think that argument is dumb because for
in Islam for example, right? When you
say like Sahaba and the companions
Like I I'm a Shia, for example. I don't
believe
that I believe some Hadiths are
incorrect. Some Hadiths are fabricated.
And Sunnis believe the same thing about
some Shias, so it's
So like it's
As a Muslim, we don't all believe that
every Hadith, every companion is 100%
this old and infallible word of God.
Again, they're just humans. They're not
a prophet speaking it. If If what you're
If you could tell me something that
Jesus said
directly from him in his words Who said
that? John? Jesus said he's recording
what what Jesus said. No, did Jesus
claim that That's Bro, you're
you're being inconsistent. Like I Like,
for example, um
can you show me where Jesus said uh I am
a servant of God in the Quran?
He says no one know
No one knows um
No one comes to me through No one comes
to me except through the Father. Oh, in
the Quran? Wait wait wait, where does
You said Jesus said that in the Bible?
Doesn't the Bible say uh no one comes
through me except through the Father?
Yeah, that's what Jesus says.
That's That's it That's in the Gospel
written by John.
Okay, yeah, that's how That's a
contradiction. How does that even make
sense? How is that a contradiction?
You're You're You're saying that one one
place where Jesus claims to be God,
where John records his words
You're saying, "Yeah, no, Jesus didn't
say that. That's not directly from
Jesus." But then you have another place
where John records his words and you're
saying, "Yeah, Jesus said this." How
would it make sense for him to be God if
he's some all-knowing God?
>> the Trinity, bro. He didn't even know
that. He didn't even know But you're
You're not You're not focused. You're
not focused, Muhammad.
You I need you to focus on your
standard. Okay. Okay?
You're saying Are you Are you rejecting
that Jesus said, "I give you eternal
life"? Are you rejecting that he said
that?
I I
Wait, who's If John said it John didn't
say it. Jesus said.
According to who? John John's writing
it.
Yeah, okay, yeah, no. I I I don't
believe that he said that. Why?
Because how how can we trust John? How
do we How can we
>> Because your Because your Quran says the
gospel that the Christians had is true
and they had John.
That's my point. They had what I have.
Well, I I don't know, honestly. I don't
know. Then you shouldn't doubt it. I got
to look into it, but but still I do see
contradictions like with within the
entire thing.
>> If you're saying you see contradictions,
then that's a flag against the Quran for
confirming a book full of
contradictions.
Now, I don't believe that there's
contradictions, but if we're going to go
with that, then the Quran is false cuz
it's saying that the Bible is true.
>> there's a reason, otherwise the Quran
wouldn't have been made. Prophet
Muhammad wouldn't have been sent.
>> I'll tell you why the Quran was made and
Muhammad is sent. He's not sent by God.
The Quran isn't made by God.
>> he sent by? It's a false Look, Jesus
says this.
After me after this is going to be a day
and times where false prophets will come
and successfully deceive many.
Successfully.
You have Muhammad as one of them.
They will come professing that they're
in line with me.
Come professing that
uh that they're in line with the Christ,
that they are sent by God.
Do not fear them because I told you this
beforehand. He says this in Matthew
chapter 24. Okay, but doesn't the Bible
also say that a prophet will come from
desert of Sinai? Have you heard of that?
>> No. No, there's no problem There's no
No, it doesn't say that. Yeah, it does.
No, I I I'm already seeing something.
>> It's Deuteronomy 33. I know the video
you're talking about. Deuteronomy 33 it
talks about how God shone forth from
Sinai. That's talking about when God
showed up to Moses and gave him the 10
Commandments
10 Commandments. Yeah, wasn't that
modern day Saudi Arabia? No, bro. That
hap- that happened.
Deut- Deuteronomy 32 33 is talking about
what God did for Israel in the past, how
he showed up for
Moses, gave him the law, gave the
Israelites the law and all that kind of
stuff.
So, Okay. uh In regards to this though,
um
Jesus So, we have we have the words of
Jesus. We have him claiming to be God
and the Quran is affirming the gospel
that the Christians have, which is what
John wrote.
You know what I'm saying? So, to to say
that to go against this would be
to go against what the Quran says. And
the reason why this is this is a problem
is because the Quran is not from God.
That's why this inconsistency exists.
Okay, look, I mean you're finding one
thing and It's a huge thing. I don't I
don't I got to look into the reasoning
of that, but I mean could I tell you
some contradictions of the Bible, for
example, of why I feel your Bible is
inconsistent and doesn't make any sense?
Yeah, go ahead. Okay, for example,
um I know Orthodox Muslims have talked
about this. Um how old was Isaiah when
he um Ahaziah? You Yeah.
Cuz then it doesn't say he's 22 in one
and um
another age in another. Depends on what
manuscript you're asking about.
There's there's there's a manuscript
that says he was 22.
Yeah, there's a there's a textual
variant. Most of the manuscripts say he
was 22 in both verses.
So, it's just a textual variant.
So, what was the Bible he was reading
from? Huh?
>> What what variant was he reading from?
Uh I the Masoretic text, I believe it
is. The Masoretic text is a Hebrew
Uh so, you don't believe it?
So, you don't believe it's two, that
variant? No. Because we have the correct
ones.
So, that's that's what I'm saying. Like
we we have
we have manuscripts and scrolls that
corroborate each other that we can point
out when someone when a scribe messed
up, you know? And that's just one of the
ones where they messed up?
>> Yeah. It's copyist error. Okay, how do
you know which ones are not messed up
and which ones are correct right
[clears throat] now? Because we have
manuscripts and scrolls that corroborate
each other.
You know? It's like uh if we had a
classroom full of 20 students and I
wrote a letter I'm the teacher who wrote
a letter and I told 20 students to copy
it. Copy this letter, right? Um and so,
everybody copies it, but there's two
students who, let's say, miscopy a word
or miss a line or something like that.
But the 18 other students copied it
correctly. You We would be able to know
which manuscripts were wrong because
there's 18 ones that say the same thing
and corroborate each other while there's
two that got something wrong, you know?
Okay, sure. What What about the
um
What about in the Trinity where um
or in the Bible when God says when Jesus
says that um
he didn't know the hour, but you guys
believe God is all-knowing. Yeah. So, if
he didn't know the hour,
how would it make him all-knowing?
So, you're saying that if he says he
doesn't know something or there's a
point that he doesn't know something,
that that means he's not God.
Yeah, cuz God is the all-knowing,
all-powerful, omni-benevolent. So, would
you be consistent with your logic if I
showed you the same thing in the Quran?
Of what?
>> [laughter]
>> Of Allah not knowing something or
claiming to not know something until a
certain day.
>> Yeah, you cannot do that. You sure? I'm
100% sure. So, if I show you that, then
what?
You're not going to be able to.
>> [laughter]
>> Show me. I got you, brother. Okay, bro.
I got you. [snorts] And then this will
be a
I'll let you get like the last word to
say your if you want to make a point,
and then um
Oh, yeah, sure. I can't be too long here
anyway. But it was fun, bro. This is an
awesome conversation, bro.
>> Yeah, wait, is this going to be on
TikTok? I'm just learning. Not Well,
yeah. Yeah, it'll be on TikTok. The full
thing will be on YouTube. Oh, okay. Mhm.
Um all right. So, chapter 19 verse 11.
>> Also, did you debate a the Orthodox
Muslim like recently? I I heard someone
I I heard I heard someone someone
ducking. I don't I debated him I debated
him like six maybe eight months ago.
That was our That was the last time I
spoke to him. Oh, I got I got I got to
watch that. The last time we He was uh
supposed to come to my live and have a
conversation, but he flaked and didn't,
so Mhm.
Okay.
So, we're going to read in context,
which is obviously good, okay? All
right. So, um this is chapter 19, Surah
Maryam,
verse We're going to start at verse 68.
It says uh
Okay.
It says, "And by your Lord, verily, we
shall assemble them and the devils. Then
we shall bring them crouching around
hell."
"Then we shall pluck out from every sect
whichever of them was most stubborn in
rebellion of the beneficiary."
"Then, verily, we know best those who
are most worthy of being burnt therein."
So, Allah says it's not until after It's
not until after he pulls the worst from
the group
that that's when he'll know who's
deserving to burn in hell.
He doesn't know before.
He says, "Then, verily, we know best
who are those who are most worthy
deserve to burn there."
How does that show that he doesn't know
everything? Cuz it's a sequence of
events. It's a point where he he's he
learns it. So, he gets the people
the the devils and the evil people, the
disbelievers.
He then
uh separates the worst from among them.
And once he does that, then he'll know
who's most deserving to burn in hell.
It's not until after he separates the
group.
He doesn't know before.
Well, are you are you serious? He's
saying that he's pulling out these
people, right?
>> Mhm. And these people are most deserving
of hell. He says, "Then we know."
After he pulls out the people, then we
know best.
Not before.
Then means after.
>> uh
It's just
Okay, look. For you got to see it like
this. It's It's an Arabic translation to
English, okay? And what he says that
Allah
>> which means then.
To come after.
It's like then this, then this, then
this.
>> saying the Quran is saying that Allah
did not know when they were on Earth
that who was the most deserving.
>> Yeah, but if we read it if we read it
verbatim how it is, yeah.
That makes zero sense. I agree.
No, I mean like
He He would have He already does know
who's most deserving of hell. He is He's
just like saying like, "Okay, yeah,
after we pull them up, we then we know."
>> Yeah, because after you die, God judges
your sins.
>> But he already knows that. But he
already knows before that, right?
>> He does, but he's telling it to us that
when when we die and we arise to God,
he's going to judge He's going to We're
going to We're going to have to face the
consequences of our sins. Oh, so you're
saying So, you're saying it's not really
that Allah's gaining cognitive
knowledge, but it's when he's making it
known who's deserving to burn there.
He's basically declaring it, not that he
doesn't know. When he says, "Then we'll
know who's deserving to burn there,"
it's like he's That's he he's making it
known to everyone who deserves to burn
there. He's declaring it.
>> That's exactly what I mean, yeah. And
it's the same thing in the verse where
Jesus is talking about no one knowing
the hour. He's not talking about
cognitive knowledge in regards to
himself, but declared it, making known
the hour to others. So,
um when he says it's not it's it's not
the man nor the angels nor the son of
the son of God, but the Father only,
right? Means that the it's for the
Father alone to declare or make known
the day and hour.
>> Yeah, not him whatsoever.
>> Yeah, it's not for him to make it known.
It doesn't mean that he doesn't know it.
He knows all things. So, if you follow
it, he may he gives a parable comparing
the situation. He says, "This is like
This is like a master
who goes away." Cuz he's talking about
him his own coming, right? Cuz that's
the hour is him leaving and then coming
back, right? Returning. That's the hour.
So, he says, "This is like a master who
goes away on a long journey.
And he puts his servants in charge of
his house, right? And so, the servants
don't know when the master is going to
come back. So, they need to stay be and
stay vigilant. Or else the master will
come home and find you guys sleeping and
playing around and messing up. So, the
master in this parable is Jesus,
obviously, going the one who's going
away. Right? And he's coming back. And
let me ask you this,
does the master who leaves does a master
who leaves his house
not know when he's going to come back to
his own house?
Um
I mean, depends. Like, he home
when he gets back, he gets back. Yeah,
but a master knows when he's going on a
journey to do his job. He knows when
he's going to come back to his house,
right?
Approximately, sure. So, the same in the
same way, Jesus, who's going away on a
long journey, knows when he's going to
return. He knows his own coming, just
like the master who goes away knows when
he's coming back to his own house.
He gives that parable. Okay. You know?
So, it's it's just about making it the
hour known. It's not for him to do, it's
not his job. He humbly leaves that job
for the father.
But does he know when the hour what a
prophet
>> Yes, he knows all things. The Bible says
he knows all things.
>> Okay, but then why
Okay, let's say we use your argument.
Then why Then why would why wouldn't he
have said, "Okay, yeah, I know the
hour." Or would he say, "I do not know
it." No, he said
again, so I'll say the same thing with
Allah. Since Allah knows all things, why
did he say, "Then we know best."? Why
didn't he just say, "We already know
who's deserving of burning there."?
Because of what I said, because um I
know. I'm with
>> He He already did know. Exactly. So, he
didn't have to say
>> we already went through this. He already
did know. But in in this example with
Jesus, he he didn't know. That's the
whole point. He's saying, "I don't know.
Only the father knows."
>> See, that's And again, so we're we're
back at cuz notice, I'm I'm going to
keep you on equal scales with me.
If you are going to say that this means
Jesus doesn't know when he says this,
then you have to say be consistent and
say this means Allah doesn't know when
he said it.
He says, "Then we know best." Not
before. Then we know best. This would
mean he didn't know before. It's not
until after he plucks them out, that's
when he knows.
But did he explicitly say that um
Does anywhere in the Quran does Allah
claim that he does not know all people's
sins all people's
>> Yes. of He says that?
>> Yes, he says it in the verse I showed
you. He says it in the other words. You
want to see the other one? Yeah, what's
the other one?
>> I got you, bro.
>> [laughter]
>> That God does not know our sins well.
>> That God doesn't know something and
about the people in the cities, yes.
Those who believe in and who don't.
Is that a thing or what? Yeah.
Oh my God.
>> Want to say hi to him?
Um maybe after this. Okay.
Let me show you real quick, big dog.
Um
As you looking for
what were your thoughts on Orthodox
Muslim debating you? Did you think you
won it or Yeah, destroyed him. He
admitted that Jesus was Yahweh in a
sense.
How did he do so? He said it. We're
we're we're
Yeah, [laughter] those are the exact
words. I asked him is Jesus Yahweh? He
said he is Yahweh in a lesser sense.
And so to be Yahweh in the Bible means
you're the most high God.
And so our debate was is Jesus the most
high God in the New Testament?
>> [laughter]
>> Him acknowledging that Jesus is is
Yahweh is saying he's the most high God.
>> I'm going to watch this when I go. Yeah,
yeah.
He said he's Yahweh in a lesser sense.
So stupid.
>> Jesus is Yahweh
Um okay. Let me get this verse. All
right, quran next.com
Uh chapter 3
Um
real quick. I'm mad. I'm actually Trying
to forget the verse and my phone is
dying. Oh no.
I wish I had like things like saved that
I could like pull up. Uh I
Like I I've I've debated so many
Christians in the past.
But like I don't know this time I
I had no idea it was going to be you. I
thought it was like I just debated like
preachers not not people who
>> [laughter]
>> The preachers the preachers can't really
debate, huh? Yeah.
Yeah. No, I mean last time I was in
Nashville I was debating some
free preacher. Uh he just say
or just forgive all their sins just
forgive he wouldn't he wouldn't argue my
points. I don't know.
Yeah, he just went in preacher mode. And
that's all right man not everybody is
you know
equipped to
to engage like [laughter] that.
Uh okay.
This might take me a second because I
got to remember where it is. It's a
chapter 3 it's a within the 140s I just
forget which verse exactly. Okay.
I feel like I'm coming up. I haven't
really seen many people. Yeah, not
really.
I mean last time I wanted to come to the
Jake Lane protest I was there right
here. That's what he said that's what
they told us that this was here.
>> Yeah, this is the exact same place.
Shoot.
Okay, okay, okay.
Let me see.
Okay, here it is.
All right, so look.
So this chapter 3 verse 142 and this
this is the last one I know we're trying
to wrap up. Tap the screen. Tap the
screen. Get the likes in. Oh my gosh.
>> [laughter]
>> Um all right. So, look. So, he's going
to do a countdown.
>> Or deem thee
I got you. I got you.
Or deem thee that ye would enter
paradise while yet Allah knoweth not
those of you who really strive nor
knoweth those of you who are steadfast.
So, it says that Allah doesn't know who
strives for the religion or who is
steadfast who doesn't strive and who who
are steadfast. Let me see. All right.
Chapter 3 verse 142, or deemed ye that
you would enter paradise while yet Allah
knoweth not those of you who really
strive, nor knoweth those who are
steadfast?
So, it says Allah doesn't know.
What verse was this? Chapter 3, Surah
Imran
verse 142.
Wait, I I've never seen this kind of
website. Can I I want to look it up?
It's like I'm going to search.
Wait, what is that chapter? Chapter 3
verse 142. You got to get a an accurate
translation too, cuz a lot of stuff try
to butcher the text.
Yeah.
That's why I want to see if it's like
accurate.
Yeah. Okay.
Chapter 3 142? Yep.
You know the word lam means, right?
Lam? Yeah, lam. In Arabic?
I I don't speak Arabic, honestly. It
means to know. Hold on, this is
Do you think you are on the path of
Islam Allah proving what you
You'll notice how it says proving.
That's not what the verse says in the
Arabic.
It says lam. It means know.
That's what I said, man. These accurate
translations will butcher it.
Okay, how do you know you're not getting
the butchered one?
It's the Arabic.
Yeah, the Arabic the word is lam, which
means to know.
And it says that Allah knows not.
Let me see the reflection for I haven't
I've never seen that before. I know.
But again, this is my point. Cuz I
wouldn't say that this means that Allah
doesn't actually know.
It means that Allah is not making it is
not declaring it or making it evident to
the others, not that he himself doesn't
know.
That would be my understanding of this.
Which is the same understanding I have
for Jesus. It's not for It's not when he
says
only uh the son doesn't know,
not that it's cognitive knowledge, but
that he's not making it known to others.
He's It's not for him to declare it or
make it known. That's for the father to
do. Okay, but it means like like I'm
being tested every day, right? And you
are being tested every day and to see if
we really are who we say we are.
Then it says that and that we must prove
it. And that's what I'm not That's what
I'm saying. He's making it evident or
declaring it to you. You don't know.
It's not that he doesn't. It's the same
for Jesus. Jesus knows all things.
But when it And so when it comes to the
hour, he knows his own return. Just like
the example he gives with the master, he
knows his own return. The thing is, it's
not for him to declare his return.
That's for the father to declare.
The thing is is that whenever the father
declares something, he does it through
the son. The son is what who makes
whatever the father wants people to
know, the son makes it known to others.
So.
Okay. Well, I I'm going to I'm going to
look into these verses.
>> Yeah, man.
Is God?
Is [music] God?